yesterday we had a session with the
financial services group cleaning about
innovation saying that innovation is not
always a good thing it might be
something that could destabilize the
financial services sector as it did
between 2008 and 2009 so rather than
thinking about just promoting innovation
we may want to think about what type of
innovation were promoting we want to
think about how we're building the
architecture of sectors sectors from
healthcare to financial services to
education that have systemic impacts
where change can be good for some but
not for others we need to start thinking
critically about what a change when to
change and how to assess it exempting
you